who that's my hilarious impression of
Anastasia Steele every other scene 50
shades of grey I never once got a boner
sad sad story I walked into this film
thinking like yeah it's not gonna be the
greatest I at least wanted to walk away
thinking like the sex was [ __ ] hot
though I'm disappointed to report that I
almost fell asleep a few times not once
in my life have I ever come close to
falling asleep during a sex scene
oh man at first like the first 30
minutes I was like yeah it's not a good
film but it's cheesy it's fun I couldn't
stop laughing kept pissing off my
girlfriend because she was really
enjoying it but I can't go into your
girlfriend if you know it's gonna be bad
but honestly after like 30 minutes
elapsed for me just stopped and I
started getting really bored this film
is like Hollywood's definition of trying
to be edgy honestly my bein it's not
that edgy here's my biggest issue with
the film this sex maybe I'd become
immune to this kind of sex from watching
dominating porn some of the best porn
there is James Dean not the actor the
porn actor James Dean fantastic and I've
actually met people who do this kind of
stuff but the way all the sex was
captured it felt like really Hollywood
it out Hollywood it could have been raw
could have been edgy authentic but
instead it was like glamorized like with
the music the feedings the fade-out it's
kind of montaging it like yes the sex is
more a heavy-handed than a typical
Hollywood flick sure yet I feel like
they played it way too safe like what
was he even wearing a [ __ ] condom I
don't care if it's in the book condoms
are not necessary all they do is get in
the way they also blame it on the actors
for not really having chemistry it just
felt like actors being put into sex
scenes it didn't feel like characters
feeling really hot and heavy like the
first act when Anastasia and Grave
you know each other was like what the
hell is happening right now why why are
they so infatuated each other why are
they so obsessed exactly I don't get
what's going on it was funny but it was
still like what the [ __ ] is happening
right now Jamie Dornan
as Christian grant let's be honest he is
so whatever in this room I just don't
see what the appeal of this dude is the
dude at one point says he's good with
people yet this guy had barely any charm
he was so [ __ ] serious the whole time
from my understanding he's supposed to
be someone who kind of confuses the
audience like at times he's just really
charming and then the next moment he'll
be really angry like he would have like
mood swings that were really contained
but in the film he was just primarily a
serious dude this guy was clearly
playing notes he didn't have like a
three-dimensional performance I don't
need to hear a lot of his background or
something but you can still have layers
of depth to your role even in the silent
moments you just feel the director
telling every actor do it like this do
like this Dakota Johnson as Anastasia
Steele she's actually not bad in the
film I felt like she handled whatever
direction was given to her pretty well
honestly it might be the best thing out
of this movie her performance she gets
the awkward shy being down in a more
authentic way compared to like Kristen
Stewart in Twilight only reason I'm
doing that is because this is supposed
to be like Twilight fan fiction so it's
okay to compare for you people who were
like stop doing it I mean there were the
occasional moments were still felt a
little forced but overall it was better
acting than everyone else but here's the
problem the interaction between
Christian and Anastasia like I said in
the first 30 minutes made no [ __ ]
sense they didn't start off with like
sexual chemistry there's no romantic
chemistry I get that yes there's
supposed to be two different people and
they're supposed to be awkward but
chemistry should still be present
especially when these two are going
apeshit over each other they didn't mean
halfway when it came to their
performances it was like he did his
thing and she did her thing
and she did her thing a lot better than
he did his thing
how else about there was like no real
[ __ ] story there is nothing like ever
at stake there's no real external
conflict and there's no real internal
conflict with the characters either the
film wasn't an exploration of the
unusual sex world
there wasn't a like romantic story being
felt it was like watching two people go
about their lives and boning a little
bit harder than before even though I
didn't expect much from this movie and I
get some a little upset because I saw a
lot of potential you hear about
Christian Grey's sexual past when he was
15 you find out Anastasia's a virgin and
then honestly like this is just one hell
of an abusive relationship like
exploring that more would have been
interesting to me they kind of touch on
it but not so like close to the end this
film like touches on all those things
but they never met any of them - it's
like halfway to its potential it's
[ __ ] it's abusive this film is really
all about that like this Christian Grey
guy is not that likable other than the
fact that he's rich and has a lot of
toys but nothing about it was like I can
see why a girl is falling for him the
only way I can see a girl falling for
this guy is if she's a victim of abuse
and she's drawn to abusive personality's
now maybe we discover that in the
sequels I don't know I just felt like
there was no real drama until like the
last 20 to 30 minutes of this film
people have defended this film though
saying like that's how it is in the book
first off I don't give a [ __ ] for that
excuse when it comes to any adaptation
that's right I'm standing my ground look
this book sold more than Twilight that
Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows
part-2 more than a DaVinci Code which
are way more creative books started for
Twilight in that category but it is a
slightly more mental than my opinion and
I think it's great I think this film
pushes the boundaries in terms of like
length of how much sex they expose and
yeah there's sex scenes in it that are
unusual that we're not used to seeing
and especially in for such a long period
of time but in terms of like the feeling
that you generate from it it somehow it
doesn't feel edgy I'm sure I might have
taken this film a little bit more
serious because like I was pissing off
my girlfriend the whole time by laughing
so I was like trying to take it
seriously but I think you'll enjoy this
film or if you don't take it seriously
all I care for was a cheesy fun time and
to get a little turned on when I was
watching some hot sex scenes but I wound
up being bored and nothing is worse than
being bored nothing good comes from
being bored except coming when you're
bored that you usually fills the time
pretty well let me get straight to the
point here oh no I gotta say Fifty
Shades of Grey
got it flaccid ly wrong alright guys
thanks for checking out our review for
Fifty Shades of Grey
why don't you go to that comment box
below and tell me 50 different sex
positions I'd love to read all those
comments last but not least if you want
to get updated every time one of my
reviews or videos is out going to click
on this button about my dig to subscribe
that's right the dick let me say
something out this little Christian he
has sinned through the gray of 15
vaginas